[Music]
the boys
of why don't we are always living their
best lives
but even pop stars have embarrassing
moments stay tuned for the most
horrifying moments
caught on camera from the members of why
don't we
are you obsessed with all the latest
bands shows and
movies we are too be sure to hit that
subscribe button
now let's check out those super
embarrassing moments of everyone's
favorite boy band
age is just a number the members of why
don't we went on mtv's total request
live and played a drinking game about
their most embarrassing moments
don't worry they were just sipping
orange juice the first question that
they were asked
have you ever lied about your age to
hook up with an older girl
well the boys are all pretty young but
we definitely didn't expect
zack herron to fess up the youngest
member of the band took a sip of his
orange juice
and looked super embarrassed this is a
super embarrassing thing to admit
at least he didn't make up too big of a
lie he said that he was 19 years old and
he's definitely not
the host of trl and the other band
members thought this was hilarious
he did not say whether or not his lie
actually worked we wonder if he got that
date or not
maybe the mystery woman realized he was
just a kid poor zack
it must be hard to be the only underage
member of the band
he didn't say when it happened but he
acted so shy that we bet it was pretty
recently
we bet his bandmates gave him a really
hard time about it too
turn off your mic every performer knows
one very important rule
don't forget to turn off your mic when
you're backstage but during a tour
one of the band members definitely
forgot this golden rule
when it was jack's turn to do his
acoustic cover all the other band
members were backstage
jack said he heard a voice in his ear it
was corbin he had forgotten to turn off
his mic
he was just talking to everyone
backstage it totally threw jack off his
game
finally someone came in and told corbin
that his mic was on
how embarrassing for both corbin and
jack but thanks to jack's quick thinking
he was able to pass it off to the
audience
he told them that the speakers were a
little muffled that's a great save jack
we wonder what it sounded like to the
audience members could they hear
corbin talking at the salon it sure
seems like the guys of why don't we do
everything together
they live together they do interviews
together and apparently they get all
their hair done together
they have such a busy schedule they
probably don't have enough free time to
go to the salon by themselves
zach decided to film his bandmates
getting their hair done
at first we see zach talking to the
camera but then he flips the camera
around to show us corbin he is totally
lost in his own little world
as zach points out corbin is playing on
his phone and is completely oblivious to
being filmed
awkward then zach pans the camera over
to jack
everyone's favorite curly-headed singer
is sitting in a salon chair his hair is
wrapped in
curlers i love you too bro
oh oh wow yeah it's hilarious and
adorable
heartbreaker one of our favorite
interviews that why don't we
has done is when they revealed all sorts
of embarrassing moments to seventeen
magazine
they were given emojis on popsicle
sticks to help answer their questions
in one question they were asked about
the most embarrassing thing that has
happened to them
in front of a crush we all know jonah
moray is basically the sweetest guy
ever we don't think he'd intentionally
hurt a girl's feelings but that doesn't
mean he isn't a little oblivious
on valentine's day at his high school a
girl who liked him decorated his locker
with lots of hard stickers when he got
to school he had no idea why his locker
was covered in hearts
i was like why are there like all these
stickers on my locker and i started
peeling them off
if that isn't bad enough the girl was
watching for his reaction
he had no idea she was watching for my
reaction
oh that's so sad we don't know how that
issue was resolved
hopefully he got a chance to explain
himself so she didn't think he was a
total jerk
skater boy we have all done some
embarrassing things in front of crushes
before
and if you haven't yet well just wait
you will
it's just part of life even the boys of
why don't we have some super
embarrassing moments with girls
corbin told 17 magazine all about his
most embarrassing moment in front of a
girl he liked
it turns out that corbin used to be a
skater boy he was really into
skateboards a few years ago
anyway corbin tried to show off in front
of this girl
and it did not go well at all i was
trying to impress this girl and i
tried to do like the simplest trick ever
where you just like jump on the board
he hit her rock and fell i hit a rock
and the bell and scraped my whole elbow
open
right in front of this girl and she's
like oh my god are you okay and i
thought i was like yeah
corbin tried to play it cool and say he
was fine but it just hurt too
bad have you had a super embarrassing
story with a crush
let us know in the comments instagram
stalking
corbin is full of embarrassing stories
or at least he's the most open to
telling his fans about them during
interviews we're all guilty of stalking
crushes on instagram or
other social media everyone does it but
no one wants to admit it
in the mtv interview all the guys
admitted that they have stalked a crush
on social media at least they are honest
but corbin had a really embarrassing
moment
everyone knows you have to be really
careful not to like a photo from too
long ago then you just looked like a
creeper corbin said he was looking at
one girl's instagram and he was way
back in her feed i was like 80 weeks
down on instagram and i was sitting with
my friend i was like yo
look at this and he reaches over and
goes omg
we cannot even imagine poor corbin we
hope he managed to unlike the photo
before she got a notification
have you ever had a cringe-worthy moment
while social media stalking
if you have sound off in the comments
think that's embarrassing stay tuned for
the most embarrassing performance moment
ever pool days we love when we get
glimpses of the boys
live on social media it makes him seem
less famous
and more real one time one of the band
members shared a bunch of videos from
their backyard
they were all swimming in the swimming
pool and goofing off and it was
hilarious
then three of the guys decide to dive
into the pool
sideways like they are old school
synchronized swimmers
they stand in a line and dive one at a
time into the water
the first two have perfect form and it
looks great but not the third band
member
we aren't sure who it is but he slips he
falls into the water
and it is not graceful at all we could
not stop
laughing they have several other pool
shenanigans where they dive into the
water
and someone is always being extra goofy
we loved it when they started jumping
over each other's floaties
don't you wish you could hang with the
guys at their pool bad auditions
we all know the why don't we boys are
super talented but it seems like not
everyone has always realized that
when you're a musician getting started
you often have to do auditions
and they are super scary corbin revealed
that when he was younger he tried out
for his school's talent show
and he did not make it how embarrassing
but we bet whatever teacher didn't let
him in
is even more embarrassed now he's a
successful pop star after all
next jack tells 17 magazine that he
tried out for american idol but he
didn't make it
he's so embarrassed that he hides his
face with a crying emoji
daniel teases him and says that his
audition went really well
we know daniel that's where we first
fell in love with your voice
but they got him back for the jab they
pointed out that daniel was eliminated
from american idol on his birthday
ouch that had to hurt can you say worst
birthday ever
oh well jokes on them daniel is even
more famous
now we're just glad that these bad
auditions didn't stop the guys from
singing
we can't imagine a world without why
don't we have you ever had a bad
audition for a talent show like corbin
swipe right the band members of why
don't we all really love each other
and one of the ways they show their love
is by pranking each other
one of the pranks is probably the
funniest of all daniel and jonah realize
that jack can be
really gullible jack was on tinder
looking for love
so daniel and jonah made a fake tender
account they wanted to try to match with
a jack
they uploaded fake pictures and we're
sure the pictures were of a girl who is
exactly jack's type
they know him pretty well after all then
they put i like boys with curly hair
as the bio they swiped right on jack's
profile
and jack swiped right back this dream
girl looked like she was less than one
mile away
poor jack was so excited he ran into the
room where the other boys were and said
this girl was the girl of his dreams
thankfully they fessed up and told him
the truth they live in a pretty elite
part of la
we wonder how he didn't even realize
that a girl that perfect would not be
right down the road
jonah was right jack really is gullible
what is the best prank you've ever
played
wardrobe malfunctions those are all
really embarrassing stories
but we've saved the most cringe-worthy
for last
embarrassing moments can happen anytime
including when the band is on stage
and that's the worst no one wants
thousands of people witnessing their
most embarrassing moments
the first wardrobe malfunction was
corbin of course
he was singing his heart out on a really
inspirational song
then he noticed several girls in the
crowd making a strange
up and down gesture it took him a moment
to realize
what they were saying but then he looked
down and realized that his fly was open
he had not zipped up his pants and the
zipper was down for the whole set
he must have been mortified did he zip
it up on stage
or wait until the song was over he
didn't say we don't know what we would
do in that situation
the next wardrobe issue might be even
worse after changing into tuxedos
and i was walking on stage and i took a
big step
up to get on the stage and i felt my
whole crotch just rip
open that might be the worst place for
pants to rip he thinks he passed it off
pretty well
by keeping his legs together we hope he
didn't accidentally flash anyone
are you brave enough to tell us your
most embarrassing moment
sound off in the comments those are the
most embarrassing moments of why don't
we
be sure to like this video and hit that
big red subscribe button to keep up with
all the latest videos